[Música]
d
estamos hoy con igor brzoska jefe de
gabinete adjunto el presidente de
ucrania
le agradecemos mucho por el tiempo que
nos conceden
hablaremos acerca de la situación actual
en ucrania buenos días señor brzoska
buenos días
primero quisiera hacerle una pregunta
acerca de las negociaciones
planea rusia están involucradas en este
difícil proceso de negociación
[Música]
cuáles son las demandas principales que
están bloqueando el acuerdo
decremento
las negociaciones se han estado llevando
a cabo desde hace varias semanas que
esta ya es la cuarta ronda de
negociaciones y desafortunadamente no ha
habido muchos resultados le recuerdo que
empezamos las negociaciones con el
acuerdo de establecer corredores
humanitarios por ejemplo pero incluso
hasta el día de hoy no todos los
corredores están funcionando bien
a veces cuando el ejército ruso promete
un alto el fuego durante la evacuación
de las personas no ocurre además cuando
se hace una negociación normal de una
negociación seria siempre hay un alto el
fuego para que mientras los diplomáticos
discuten las fuerzas armadas no
bombardee
desafortunadamente este no es el caso en
lo que respecta a las negociaciones los
bombardeos han continuado día tras día
noche tras noche hora tras hora las
fuerzas rusas están bombardeando
ciudades ucranianas están atacando
objetivos civiles mujeres niños y
civiles han sido blancos así que hasta
el momento las negociaciones todavía se
están llevando a cabo
pero están lejos de la continuidad
al mismo tiempo debo recordarle que mi
presidente está listo para tener una
negociación directa con el presidente
putin y le pedimos al lado ruso que esté
listo para estas negociaciones
deseamos que estas negociaciones se
lleven a cabo el lado ruso nos está
diciendo que las delegaciones todavía
tienen trabajo por hacer pero
desafortunadamente como se lo dije antes
nosotros esperamos muchos más resultados
de los que ha habido hasta ahora
pero que el tema está bloqueando la
negociación cuáles son las demandas de
rusia que no están aceptando
no aceptaremos ninguna demanda de rusia
que sea y realista
[Música]
estamos listos para discutir algunos
puntos pero los bloques principales que
pedimos implementar son primero un alto
el fuego
segundo la retirada de las tropas rusas
del territorio ucraniano
y luego estaremos listos para discutir
otros puntos y lo discutiremos la
entrega del territorio ucraniano nos
discutiremos saber algunas partes de
gran interés el resto de los puntos
podrían ser discutidos
así que usted no aceptaría la pérdida de
crimea dome slogans
dime a tony ex lugar antes son
territorios ucranianos y no hay un
acuerdo sobre eso
hay alguna solución que pueda ser
aceptable
de nuevo hablar que tenemos que estar en
las negociaciones por supuesto no
revelaremos los proveedores de las
negociaciones pero una vez más todo
debería estar en conjunto durante las
negociaciones uno de los temas
principales que queremos tocar como
resultado de estas negociaciones son
fuertes garantías de seguridad para mi
país que antes de la guerra no teníamos
las garantías de seguridad que corona el
mundo quedamos privados del tercer
adicionalmente al más grande en 1994 y
en su lugar lo que abrimos el memorando
de la peste en su puesto memorando
aunque no garantiza absolutamente nada
para los países sólo declaraba que los
países iban a garantizar la seguridad
del cráneo tampoco fui sino en 2014
cuando rusia empezó los ataques contra
ucrania ni en 2022 cuando rusia empezó
una guerra abierta contra gratis este
memorándum de budapest nunca funcionó
así que nos gustaría como resultado de
las negociaciones tener garantías
estrictas de la comunidad mundial para
mi país
de los países europeos de que este tipo
de agresión rusa nunca se repetirá para
conseguirlo es necesario que tengamos un
procedimiento estricto de garantías de
seguridad estos también hace parte de
las negociaciones pero
desafortunadamente por ahora no tenemos
ningún resultado sobre estos
aceptaría algún tipo de neutralidad
de nuevo podría discutirse pero solo en
combinación con las garantías de
seguridad
y es parte de la discusión que felinski
renuncia a ser presidente de ucrania
mi presidente está listo para hablar con
el presidente putin pero
desafortunadamente el presidente putin
no está listo así que su renuncia a la
presidencia no es parte de la discusión
cruz ya no los está exigiendo
no nunca hemos escuchado estas demandas
es el presidente de ucrania y lo seguirá
haciendo
[Música]
de lenski dijo que ucrania no se unirá a
la otan mantendrá su petición de unirse
a la unión europea
definitivamente en cuanto a la otan
tenemos que la nota no está lista para
aceptar a ucrania por ahora
en cuanto a la unión europea es un
proceso muy importante para ucrania a
finales de febrero mi presidente
presentó la aplicación para que ucrania
puede ser miembro de la unión europea
ayer hubo negociaciones importantes
entre mi presidente y la presidenta de
la comisión europea úrsula von der leyen
oficialmente empezamos un proceso
burocrático para procesar la aplicación
de ucrania en la comisión europea ahora
la comisión europea debe evaluar si
ucrania adhiere a los criterios de
copenhague
porque este no es el primer acuerdo que
hacemos con la unión europea tenemos el
acuerdo de asociación tenemos una zona
de libre comercio de alcance amplio y
profundo y es unimos al sistema de
energía de la unión europea así que ya
se ha hecho mucho trabajo
pero todavía queda trabajo por hacer
ucrania está lista para hacerlo muy
rápido en unas cuantas semanas pero
ahora tememos que la burocracia europea
entierre este asunto que trate de
hacerlo lo más largo posible así que le
pedimos a los miembros de la unión
europea que influyan en la comisión
europea para proceder con el proceso
rápidamente ucrania merece ser parte de
la familia europea porque ahora estamos
luchando no solo por nuestra seguridad y
por nuestros intereses nacionales
estamos luchando por los colores
europeos estamos luchando por todas en
europea así que por favor les pedimos a
los líderes europeos que sigan a sus
naciones porque si le preguntan a las
naciones
a las personas comunes y corrientes en
la calle en francia alemania españa si
quieren que los ucranianos sean parte de
la familia europea
definitivamente vengan que si más del
60% lo apoya tenemos las encuestas así
que le pedimos a los líderes europeos
que no dejen atrás la opinión de sus
respectivos países
está decepcionado con los líderes
europeos
algunos de ellos podrían apoyar un poco
más fuertemente al grado
como por ejemplo no le voy a nombrar a
los países pero todos sabemos cuáles son
los principales países de la unión
europea los agentes principales así que
de nuevo cada hora cada minuto cuenta
cada minuto y cada hora
desafortunadamente hay víctimas de
niveles ucranianos no sólo resultados
sino también civiles y cada minuto los
líderes europeos están extendiendo el
tiempo pensando si venderles municipios
adicionales a un cráneo no
así aplicarle sanciones adicionales a
rusia o no se acepta de ucrania en la
unión europea
durante cada una de estas horas y
minutos desafortunadamente ucrania sufre
todos ellos deberían acordarse de esto
varias naciones e incluso el vaticano
ofrecieron mediar en esta crisis creo
que algunos de ellos realmente puede
ayudarles por ejemplo chino
bueno proseguimos cualquier asistencia
internacional que quiera traer la paz a
ucrania en el caso de la mediación 5
varios líderes le han sugerido a mi
presidente ser mediadores o
facilitadores en nuestras negociaciones
con rusia y traer la paz ao clave que
todo el mundo puede hacer rival
desafortunadamente todavía no ha habido
resultados en cuanto a china la posición
de ese país es muy importante todos
seguimos ayer la llamada entre el líder
chino y el presidente bailén y
creemos que la posición de china debería
ser muy sabia porque china es una de las
mayores potencias del mundo
y no debería dejarse arrastrar en el
conflicto por la fundación rusa
tal como dicen algunas especulaciones
que hemos escuchado
así que esperamos sabiduría por parte
del líder chino
está en contacto con ellos con los
chinos en nuestros ministros de asuntos
exteriores hablaron hace una semana creo
estamos en contacto con china a nivel de
trabajo y estamos listos para una
conversación entre mi presidente y el
presidente de chivas
cuáles son las principales dificultades
del ejército ucraniano en este momento
en este momento necesitamos asistencia
adicional en cuanto al espacio aéreo
estamos viendo en el terreno nuestras
fuerzas armadas las que están en el
terreno son fuertes pero en lo que
respecta a la defensa aérea nos hace
falta cierto equipamiento y potenciales
por ejemplo hemos pedido a los países de
la otan que establezcan una zona de
exclusión aérea humanitaria sobre
ucrania
desafortunadamente no hemos recibido una
respuesta positiva pero en vez de eso
estamos listos para recibir cualquier
ayuda realmente necesitamos sistemas de
defensa aérea sistemas antimisiles y
aviones de combate que estamos
trabajando con nuestros aliados para que
nos den esa oportunidad si nuestros
aliados nos ayudan a cerrar el cielo que
esto nos acercará mucho a la victoria
cuál es la situación de la guerra en el
terreno
durante varios días hemos escuchado
sobre mariupol
pero puede decirme cuál es la ciudad el
área donde en este momento esté más
fuerte la guerra
pues sigue siendo el caso y
sigue siendo
desde hace varios días empezaron a dejar
que las personas
pero antes de eso no estaban dejando que
la gente evacuada
más o menos lo grande las personas
prácticamente todos los días están
bombardeando la ciudad
usted escuchó la historia sobre el
parque aéreo al teatro de mariupol
todavía no conocemos la cantidad de
víctimas en este edificio porque
desafortunadamente el ataque aéreo fue
severo pero sólo pudimos rescatar a 130
personas del edificio pero había varios
cientos adentro
para esto tal vez también vio el ataque
aéreo el hospital de maternidad el resto
de las ciudades que han logrado rodear
en el sur de ucrania tampoco están en
buenas condiciones
por ejemplo con las ciudades las afueras
de kiev han estado tratando de buscar
esas ciudades de terreno
la situación tampoco es buena en la
ciudad de sermin en el norte de ucrania
que también están tratando de establecer
pero no hay logrado capturar a por
rodear las ciudades principales ni kiev
mi jardín jude esa han sido capturadas
probablemente tratarán de hacerlo además
de bombardear el resto de las ciudades
paran de atacar que esas ciudades
principales para rodear las
en la última semana también hemos visto
varios ataques en el oeste de ucrania
ha habido dificultades en el transporte
de asistencia humanitaria militar hacia
el centro y el este de ucrania
si ese ha sido el caso quieren mostrar
que no hay ningún lugar seguro en
ninguna parte de ucrania
atacaron algunos objetivos en el oeste
de ucrania
y desafortunadamente es posible pensar
que seguirán haciendo
cómo se imagina ucrania en 10 años
un país próspero rico uno de los líderes
no de europa sino del mundo después de
que ganemos les tomará mucho tiempo
recuperarse
bueno vamos a necesitar asistencia de la
comunidad internacional de la comunidad
europea por eso desde ahora estamos
hablando con la unión europea acerca de
establecer posibles fondos de
recuperación en lo que concierne a la
infraestructura a la economía y hemos
recibido respuestas positivas a nuestras
peticiones
se arrepiente de algo que su gobierno
haya podido hacer mejor en algún momento
no solo nos arrepentimos de que la
comunidad internacional yo haya prestado
mucha atención a lo que mi presidente
estaba diciendo
cuando decía que por favor aplicarán
sanciones preventivas para que no
ocurrieron la guerra en ucrania los
líderes se mantuvieron en silencio
eso pasó en parís en alemania en españa
en otros países
ahora que empezó la guerra la unión
europea empezó a introducir algunas
sanciones que no han sido suficientes
así que de lo único de lo que me
arrepiento es que la comunidad
internacional y europea
no escucharán con atención a mi
presidente ojala presten más atención
ahora y en el futuro
gracias señor brzoska disculpe de nuevo
mi pronunciación